Speaker 1: Well, as you know, there are often
not that many things that Democrats are doing
correctly for themselves, and sometimes Democrats
are sort of relying on or hoping that Republicans
will mess themselves up. It's not a great
strategy, but to the extent that it's useful,
you do love to see it. And the latest is that
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, the repugnant and radical
Republican congresswoman from Georgia, is furious
that Tulsi Gabbard hammered Republican congressman
elect liar. Jorge Santos on Fox News two nights
ago. So let me remind you what happened. George
Santos is a huge liar, lied about his job history,
lied about his educational history, lied about
being Jewish, maybe lied about the circumstances
of his mother's death. Lie, lie, lie, lie, lie.
He appeared with Tulsi Gabbard, who used to be
a Democrat. Now she's not. Next thing you know,
Tulsi Gabbard is campaigning for Cory Lake and
Herschel Walker and filling in for Tucker Carlson.
But to her credit, Tulsi did a good job to some
degree of holding George Santos accountable.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE did not like it, unleashing
a fascinating series of tweets in so far as it
tells us a lot about how these people think about
politics. Let's look at the tweet thread. This is,
again, Marjorie Taylor. GREENE not happy with
Tulsi. Quote, Tulsi Gabbard, who says she is a
former Democrat, gave rep representative elect
George Santos zero grace while George Georgia's
admitting in apologizing for lying about his
resume just like her former colleagues are
giving Georgia zero grace and even demanding he
resign. Remember, he didn't admit and apologize.
He minimized, called them embellishments, said the
explanation would go over the voters heads because
they couldn't possibly understand it. And on and
on and on. To say it was an apology is a little
bit much. Okay, Marjorie, continuing quote, Tulsi
says that Georgia's actions on the House floor are
what is most important. But George has not even
had the chance to take action for his district
on the House floor because he isn't even sworn in
yet. Tulsi also says how can his district believe
anything he says when he is standing on the House
floor fighting for them? That's a good question.
I, too, believe actions and words are extremely
important, but I don't think a former Democrat
whose actions on the House floor as recent as
2020 that gave her an F from Planned Parenthood
and F from the NRA and introduced a climate agenda
signature piece of legislation called the AF Act
designed to end all fossil fuels the same as AOC
is green. New Deal should lecture a newly elected
Republican member of Congress on how he should
vote to represent his Republican district. Oh,
boy. Marjorie, continuing this tirade, quote, I
do appreciate that. Tulsi says words that sound
conservative now even though she can't take action
to back them up. I am glad she, like George,
realized she made mistakes and was wrong every
time she voted to support killing the unborn,
taking away our gun rights, and legislated
to kill America's energy independence and the
fossil fuel industry. I hope Tulsi is sincere,
just like I hope George is sincere. I think
we Republicans should give George Santos a
chance and see how he legislates and votes,
not treat him the same as the left is.
Listen, there is not even the smallest doubt
that we're George Santos, a Democrat, Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. And all of these people would be
treating him completely differently. And to some
degree, although I'm not a fan of Tulsi Gabbard's.
She seems to be treating him the way he deserves
to be treated based on his actions, not because of
his party designation. Similarly. I hope you all
know that my position on George Santos would be
exactly the same if he were a Democrat. And as you
all know, this idea that there's a double standard
among everybody when it comes to these wrongdoing,
these types of wrongdoing is very much untrue. I
don't know anyone on the left who was defending
Anthony Weiner when he was involved in sexting
minors and whatever, all the different things
that he did when that Democratic congressman,
I believe it was, was caught with ten grand in
his freezer. I didn't defend him. I don't know
anybody that did. It is not all the same. And
while Marjorie Taylor GREENE wants to claim
that it is the left with the double standard,
it is really her ilk, the MAGA people,
etc.. The only really good take here from Marjorie
Taylor GREENE like I would if you said to me,
David, sir, what would be an intellectually
honest reaction for Marjorie Taylor GREENE that
defends George Santos? It would be if Marjorie
Taylor GREENE came forward and said, listen.
Let's not be hard on George Santos, because at
the end of the day, our entire party really is
as dishonest as he is. Like when we say cutting
taxes for the rich is good for the economy. That's
just as dishonest and more damaging than when
he said he graduated from college. That would
be a surprisingly refreshing, accurate take
from Marjorie Taylor GREENE. Not the argument
she's making. Marjorie Taylor GREENE, as is
almost always the case, coming up with the
worse take on every issue. A constant liar, a
consistent liar. And she lacks total morals,
values and ethics. And that's part of why she has
no problem with the lies told by George Santos. I
don't hate the infighting. You all know that.
I think it's good for the left. The left needs
help. Any help the left can get. I think we should
take zooming. We're not doing anything illegal or
immoral. And certainly letting them fight among
themselves has nothing immoral or illegal to it